Following a few principles,
we make forms a breeze for your users.
Which ultimately means
more conversions for you.
One, make forms as short and
sweet as possible.
Avoid making any redundant information
and auto-fill as much as possible.
Two, provide helpful prompts.
In the last lesson you did
it with the label elements.
Three, provide immediate feedback.
Feedback comes in many different shapes.
In the last lesson, you get feedback
on an input with an instant validation.
In this lesson, you'll use progress
bar to provide feedback on the users
progress through the entire form.
You can learn about these principles and
more through the link in
the instructor notes.
Now that these principles are fresh in
your mind, Ken is going to help
you do some brainstorming.